hello my name is Karen warden with film
courage the radio show as you may or may
not know David and I have the pleasure
of attending tomorrow's 25th annual
spirit awards in los angeles and we're
putting a call to action out to you we'd
like you to email us any questions you
have for some of the attendees we're
going to do our best to be out with our
camera and ask some of the people
attending questions and we'd love to
hear from you you know lee daniels lynn
shelton greg mottola Robert Kenner any
of these great people please shoot us an
email tell us what you like us to ask
and to whom you'd like us to ask it to I
hope that's proper English maybe not
whatever anyway we're just hoping for
some some feedback and we're going to do
our best to go out and ask some
questions so please film courage at
gmail com and we will see you on YouTube
that's right we want to get you involved
let's go folks